so the idea is  maybe like the covington catholic kids  you will be and if you're watching you  just saw him  in a panicked way look off camera okay  suing news organizations that  maliciously lie about people who are in  the news right is that the plan  yes sir we're gonna be holding them  accountable tucker  do you  he has no idea what he's doing and you  know we're laughing at it because it's  so it's impossible you know to avoid  laughing  but we really should almost like feel  bad that now he's clearly being taken  advantage of and it's not even clear  whether if you donate money to this  media accountability project tmap the  media accountability project it's not  even clear the money really will be used  for lawsuits i mean remember this is a  very common right wing grip